what superman can go all black and so
can i
zach snyder's justice league
it's out i've seen it
all four hours plus of it here's the
here's the thing that's really difficult
for me here's where i'm actually having
a really hard time formulating my
thoughts
i'm not entirely sure how to frame a
conversation around this thing
because what this movie i'm just going
to call it a movie for lack of
anything else to call it what it is
is a very unique thing i don't mean the
subject matter
the end result i mean why it exists
and why it exists in the form that it
does
because let's be very clear about one
thing
this is not the movie that we would have
gotten released to
theaters had zack snyder not left
after the pro after the preliminary
round of shooting
for justice league and had joss whedon
not taken over if that
if those events hadn't happened and he
had been allowed to finish that movie
and release the theaters
what we get right now on hbo max is not
what that movie would have been it's
it's not
because the amount of freedom that he
was granted on this which warner
brothers kind of had to give him because
the entire pitch was
this was his unfiltered untouched vision
for what the film was
this was never going to be released to
theaters
ever not at this length and not
at this expense and i will remind you
that despite being initially budgeted at
an additional 35 million dollars on top
of what they already spent on justice
league the first time around
this ended up doubling that and costing
them about another 70 million
so between the cost and the fact that a
four-hour movie is going to have fewer
turnovers in a day which means fewer
people are going to get to see it again
which is going to hit your box office
and hate your bottom line
this was never going to be released to
theaters
so what we don't have is a glimpse into
what the movie would have been
and in addition to that before anyone
counters well originally justice league
was going to be two movies and this is
that
this absolutely isn't that either
because there's
no point at you know lengthwise four
hours it's long enough that you could
say well it's
two it's two two hour movies crammed
together structurally though it's not
there's nothing even approaching a
feasible
stopping point anywhere close to the
half point of this
there actually really isn't a decent
stopping point till about three hours in
and then you've got a second movie
that's only an hour long and nothing but
action
so no that doesn't fly either
so what we have is a
four hour seven chapter probably the
closest thing i could think to call it
is a mashed together miniseries because
the seven chapters
run about half an hour 35 minutes some
of them 40ish minutes
and they just run back to back to back
except it's not really that either
because each chapter is not
self-contained enough that it would
actually function
as an episode which is probably why
despite the rumors early on that hbo max
was going to release this
as a mini series they ultimately
released it as one chunk because
these chunks wouldn't be satisfying on
their own
it really does have to be watched as a
continuous thing but
all right i've kind of d i've kind of
been dancing around the issue and
avoiding talking about
how is it okay
is this better than the justice league
that was released to theaters
oh yeah oh yeah unquestionable it was
always going to be
no matter what your opinion of zack
snyder's take on these heroes is
this was always going to be a better
film because it was made under better
circumstances
because the cut that was released
theatrically was a
hodgepodge of a mostly shot film taken
over by a completely different director
who went through extensive reshoots but
couldn't shoot the whole thing from the
ground
up and still have to repurpose a lot of
stuff that was in somebody else's vision
just by the frankensteinian nature
of that theatrical cuts production
this was always going to be better just
for the sake of coherency
and for appearing like a properly
fleshed out
and thought out single product as
opposed to a
mad scramble to mash up something
because we have to get something into
theaters otherwise
our shareholders are going to hang us
out to dry
so yes unquestionably this is better
than the
theatrical justice league and in case
anyone doesn't
know my opinion on that which at this
point a lot of people probably don't
while i'm not really one to defend it as
a film
i did kind of enjoy the theatrical
release of justice league
although admittedly a lot of that
probably had to do with lowered
expectations in the first place but i
came out and was like
i had fun so that's kind of where i was
at that one i never bothered to re-watch
it i suppose that's another thing
i neither re-watched the theatrical cut
of justice league for comparison
purposes
nor did i reach re-watch batman v
superman knowing that this was going to
directly pick up from that
uh and actually it's funny it's funny my
first note
uh because i actually do take notes
sometimes my first note that i took was
oh crap
should i have re-watched batman be
superman again uh thankfully i really
didn't have to
i mean you kind of need to have seen it
at least
once because this is building off enough
of it that
if you don't know what happened in
batman v superman you are gonna be lost
at the starting status quo of this film
but
it's building off the broad strokes and
it does not call back to enough of the
specifics
at least that i caught that it becomes a
necessity that you need to have
refreshed yourself on the previous film
which is good because batman v superman
is still a bad movie and this movie
being
all right here it goes actually pretty
good
does not retroactively make batman v
superman a good movie
that is still a bad movie but this thing
looking at it on its own i thought i was
going to be in for basically a four hour
hangover
this was a pretty good movie this is i
would actually argue
probably the best film that zack snyder
has made
i say there's someone who has a very
mixed feelings about
most of his filmography but i don't
dislike all of his stuff
i liked dawn of the dead i love
300 i don't like watchmen did a whole
video on my problems with that
and i sucker punch was ah man of steel i
saw what he was
going for it didn't work for me batman v
superman was a disaster
this this is a really solid piece of
work
and probably owing to the fact that he
was
given as much true control
this time and i underline that word true
control because people
probably can try and argue that he had
pretty strong control over batman v
superman and he
did except he also didn't because he
still had to work within the confines of
what was expected of a major
blockbuster in terms of setting up the
other things because
look i don't doubt that snyder was the
one who decided what they were going to
be and how they were going to be
integrated into the film
but i have a very hard time believing
that were he not
making it with the insistence of the
people funding the thing that he set up
a whole bunch of other movies
that things like the little mini
trailers
for flash aquaman and cyborg would be in
there
or that the dream sequence well maybe
the dream sequence but like there's a
bunch of stuff in that movie that i have
a hard time buying he would have put in
unless he was either told or
strongly believed because it would have
been the reasonable assumption
that they needed to be for this to set
up a whole bunch of franchise stuff
in terms of actually telling a story a
bunch of that stuff didn't need to be
there
is this thing totally devoid of setup
stuff
no although it is pretty much largely
relegated to an epilogue and the
epilog's about the one part of this
thing that i actually don't particularly
care for
but not because it's setting up a whole
bunch of other stuff for other reasons
i'll come back to it
but setting the epilogue aside for a
moment
this really does work
and i think it works and what it made me
realize is
what snyder does or what his instincts
as a director kind of drive him to do
if you're going to have him do any story
more complicated than
there's a battle between the spartans
and the persians
and that's kind of the whole movie then
you need to give him enough time where
what he
does which is a lot of slow build
a lot of slow motion and a lot of
frankly on the nose needle drops for
that stuff to work it needs breathing
room because if it doesn't have the kind
of breathing room that a
four hour run time gives it then that
means that it is eating up time that
would be better spent actually moving
things forward
and refining and tightening the story
because i found myself watching this and
there's a bunch of stuff in here that
i'm not going to say for whatever this
thing
is that it was a bad idea to include but
i can tell you absolutely would have
been trimmed
to heck had this been the theatrical
release good example for that
is the extended action scene where
steppenwolf
uh quick note on his design i still
don't love the look but i will say that
the design that he has in this
absolutely justifies him being a 100 cgi
creation
whereas the look in the theatrical
honestly there was no reason for him to
be 100
cgi for that look they could have done
that practically so it is kind of a case
of if you're gonna go
full cgi at least have the design be
something that you couldn't do
practically
which this is so you know points for
that but when steppenwolf attacks
paradise island and the amazons to to
take control of the mother box is the
first one he gets his whole
his hands on the action scene involved
in this
is it comes in waves because
first of all you have the pair of demons
arriving you have steppenwolf arriving
you have an extended action scene inside
the sort of stone temple
thing which is not short but that ends
with um uh hippolyta grabbing the mother
box getting out they
collapsed the tunnels to the temple
thing and they dropped the temple into
the ocean
hoping that that stops stefan wolf he
gets out and then
you have basically an action chase scene
where they're trying to
run the mother box away from him and he
is fighting amazon it's amazon's trying
to slow him down so
if this were a theatrical release that
entire second part
of the chase is the kind of thing that
you would cut
not because it wasn't good it was but
when you are trying to confine to a
reasonable run time for a theatrical
relief which usually tops out about two
and a half hours
three at a stretch if you can really
sort of justify that it's definitely
gonna put all the butts in seats i mean
let's not forget the only reason end
game got away with a runtime as long as
it had
is because it was the culmination of 10
years of one of the most successful
ongoing franchises in film history
otherwise they wouldn't have tried it
and they wouldn't have gotten away with
it but if you're not allowing that kind
of run time
the entire second half of this the chase
aspect of it
you would have cut because ultimately so
early in the film and he's got three of
these things to collect
there's no doubt he is going to get a
hold of it so stretching that out
further
doesn't really benefit anything when
you're trying to be more economical with
your runtime
when you throw the rules of economical
use of time
completely out the window which this
does then honestly
it doesn't feel like the same kind of
waste of
time that it would have that would have
resulted in
that second half of this action scene
being cut in a theatrical release
or at least trimmed down substantially
so what uh another example
is with batman looking for
barry allen there are a number of setups
for that there is
um some scenes that he that bruce has
with
alfred ahead of time and this whole
thing that wasn't in the theatrical
with barry applying for jobs and there's
this
action scene where we see his powers on
display where he saves
a character who is presumably iris west
seems to be
implicated at least and the
nature of that while it demonstrates his
power so do later scenes anyways
and the sort of reminding us that he's
looking for him here's where he is in
the search of him
here's barry and sort of all those
pieces
are what you would drop so that you
could basically do a quick reminder that
batman's looking for him and then jump
to
batman showing up where barry lives and
then having the scene as it plays out
from there so
again it's those kinds of things are the
sorts of things that would have been cut
from a standard theatrical film
but having them here and allowing the
whole thing to
just take more time actually allows for
the kinds of indulgences that snyder
likes to do
play properly because it's
not feeling like it's wasting time that
could be better spent somewhere else
he's got
four hours to play with why not use it
to do this
now that's not me saying the man should
just be allowed to make four hour movies
like that's not gonna happen not with
not with things of this kind of budget
like i said at the start this was never
gonna be released to theaters as we see
it
but for what it is it's
pretty good now like i said i didn't
refresh myself on the theatrical version
of justice league so i could not go
through point for point
and really break down everything that is
different about it
that having been said a lot of
the additions are between the action
scenes the things that are largely the
same although in some cases
extended like i mentioned with the
amazons versus steppenwolf
the action scenes are actually the
closest to being
unchanged from the theatrical release
which makes a lot of sense
because the easiest stuff to adjust in
reshoots would have been the connective
tissue between those action scenes
as opposed to starting from scratch on
the access action scenes themselves
because
those take so much work in terms of
preparation pre-visualization and how
long the effects work takes on them
the idea of reshooting those was
probably never in the cards
so pretty much all the action scenes
that you saw in the theatrical version
are here
in some form again generally a little
bit of
a little bit extended but there aren't
really any new action scenes that were
created out a whole cloth
they're all in both versions to some
degree
most of what was added here was just the
stuff in between
and there is a difference in tone
obviously
this is darker and more serious barry
allen actually does a pretty good job at
lightening the mood at least at times so
that not everybody is a brooding misery
guts because
yeah most of them are if the character
who's probably
done the best in terms of improvement
from the
previous version in addition to
steppenwolf but that's largely cosmetic
although that cosmetic difference does
actually help a fair amount
but beyond that it's cyborg it's victor
stone
and given what ray fisher has said about
his experience working with joss whedon
on justice league it's actually kind of
rewarding to see the character
get done justice here oh god that i
didn't mean to
use that choice of words anyways much
more so than he wasn't the theatrical
release because we get
time spent on his origin what happened
to him
prior to him becoming cyborg his
relationship with his father
and just getting a sense of who he is
and where he's at
we understand him as a character a hell
of a lot better here than we
ever had a shot at doing in the
theatrical version
so if you felt cyborg was short shifted
before
he gets a pretty good run in this one
there really aren't too many other major
changes at least as far as the
characterization goes for anybody
else because like i said the there's a
it's a little bit
jokier in tone in the theatrical version
but all the
roles that people are playing their
function in the story in the script it's
exactly the same as before
this is actually way less changed
from the theatrical version than i
expected i expected a lot more very
substantive changes especially given how
many headlines there were about
all of the cut characters from before
who were now going to be in
this but the thing is nearly all of
those are
cameos and most of them don't amount to
all that much
the one who probably gets the most
additional stuff is well i was going to
say dark side but it's not even a really
dark side it's desaad who is dark side's
right hand but sure dark side by
extension
but he doesn't really become a presence
he's just a looming threat something
that will probably have to be dealt with
later within the actual story being told
no he doesn't really do all that much
and then there are additions
like the martian man hunter whose
initial appearance is
weird i don't i don't
really know why but the and the thing is
like i'm tilting my head at things like
that but again when
something is this long and allowed this
much breathing room
a moment like that doesn't seem as
egregious because
again you're not really wasting time
you've got the time to spare
now let's talk about superman
specifically
i was expecting the most drastic shift
in terms of
him and there both is
and there isn't the way things actually
play out with him
are actually not that far off at all
from how they were in the theatrical
version i mean the main difference is
the black suit but in addition to that
there's less
active work being done in this to
really try and establish the kind of
light that superman was
supposed to be and never was so what's
sort of odd is this film still
behaves as if superman is
or was this wonderful hopeful sign of
light and peace and hope in the world
even though that wasn't really in
evidence in either of the previous two
movies but this still kind of behaves
like it does which means one
of two things and i can't say which it
is either
snyder kind of realized he had failed to
properly make superman a symbol of hope
and altruism and just kind of
pretended that he had and then moved
forward as if that had always been the
case
or he genuinely thought that he had and
didn't recognize that no you you you
really
didn't paint him that way um
but that's sort of that's only an issue
taking on the baggage of
the previous films which you know
this doesn't exist in a vacuum but as a
solo viewing experience
superman's actually handled pretty well
it is odd to me that
he's at his most heroic in the black
suit and then in the epic log we have
him in
his colors again and he's evil epilogue
push back the epilogue i will get back
to that if it seems like i'm actually
being a bit
more critical of this despite the fact
that me saying it's actually quite good
that comes down to one major thing
while i think this is the best
thing that snyder has done and is
definitely the best version of this kind
of take on these heroes that i think we
would probably ever hope to get
i still don't really like uh this take
on heroes
but that comes down to a matter of taste
my disliking
the darker and more broody
version of the heroes like across the
board like for some of them i get it
batman that's like his whole bag at this
point
but having it be the tone of the entire
movie is just not
for me broadly speaking when it comes to
superhero stories
but if you are going to do that this is
a
very good version of that excellent even
it just comes down to a debate over
whether or not you feel this is the
version of these heroes that should be
getting put forth in the first place
i feel like in many ways the disconnect
for
me and for how i wish to see heroes
depicted and how
snyder chooses to depict heroes is
probably best exemplified by
not cyborg as a character but by this
voiceover we get
from victor stone cyborg's father
sort of laying out all the capabilities
of what cyborg can do
and he goes through you know you can
connect to
any network you can hack anything you
can do all this stuff
and there's a lot of emphasis
on all the bad things he could do
on how he could hack any system spy on
anybody
set off nukes if he wanted
and that the true mark of heroism
is going to be resisting the temptation
to do that
and while like there's some
nicer things in that voiceover a little
bit later the fact that it leads with
that and spends way more time
on all of the horrible things cyborg
could do
if he wasn't a better person i think
speaks a lot
to the difference in how snyder and i
view heroes or the lens through which
they view heroes because
strictly speaking saying that part of
what makes a hero
heroic is resisting the temptation to
use their abilities to do bad
things is not untrue but
i for one put a lot more weight in the
things that they
choose to do as opposed to the
temptations that they resist
i tend to think that what makes someone
heroic and admirable
is if their thought process is what's
the most
good i can do with this as opposed to
what's the least bad
and again the component parts of a
superhero in terms of
you know resisting temptation to do to
use it for selfish selfish purposes and
all the rest of that that's present in
every superhero so it's not like
snyder is pulling this out of thin air
it exists in any superhero but to come
at it from that angle as opposed to
i mean it's it's basically like
opposite sides of the john f kennedy
quote that's not what
your country can do for you but what you
can do for your country
his position basically being ask not
what
superheroes can do for you but what you
should be grateful for for superheroes
it's a very
randian perspective and like normally i
don't
dig in to the personal beliefs and
political
machinations inside the heads of
filmmakers except
that snyder's fairly outspoken
with his morandian philosophy and the
fact that he's been trying to get iran's
fountainhead made for some time
speaks to that as well and this is a
very randian take on superheroes
basically
implying because they could destroy you
you should be happy that they don't
as opposed to what is usually say
the marvel perspective certainly in the
films
you should admire these people because
they help
his perspective seems to at least lean
more towards the angle of
you should just be grateful that they
don't wreck you because they could
so suck it up and it's not a perspective
i share
but again my philosophical disagreements
with the perspective aside
that doesn't make this a bad movie which
is largely the same
angle that i come at 300 from
i have a lot of philosophical
disagreement
with a lot of the implications or flat
out stated beliefs and intentions behind
those characters and the movie as a
whole
but i still think it's a really good
movie that's
kind of where i'm at with this the
fundamental philosophical approach to
these characters is not one that i would
ever say
should be the approach to superheroes
but it's the one he chose
and he executed it well so for me
there's really no debate over whether
snyder accomplished what he set out to
do
and accomplished it well the only point
of contention is whether it's
whether or not something he should have
been doing in the first place
and sometimes that can be a little bit
more clear-cut
in this case i'm prepared to say that's
largely going to be a matter of taste
so if this approach that
he takes to it really i mean it rubs me
the wrong way somewhat but if it really
rubs you the wrong way to the point that
you're kind of
appalled that i even say it's a good
movie i get it
if you love this so much that you're
kind of annoyed with me that i say that
i'm disagreeing with the philosophy of
it
i get it but
that's just kind of where i'm at with
this thing up until the epilogue
the epilogue really feels like the one
bit that i'm like what why
why why is that there i suppose in
theory it's there to try and pay off the
nightmare
stuff from batman v superman
except it really doesn't it's just more
set up for what would have theoretically
been the follow-up to this
and what i don't like about it
is that especially given how
tonally dark and how
broody a lot of characters are i was
surprised at how
uplifting the film
felt by the time steppenwolf was
defeated
it was uplifting and affirming
and hopeful in a way that batman v
superman
never even came close to being
so the fact that managed to do that with
this overall
dark desaturated tone i was actually
really impressed by
but that sense of hope and triumph
is absolutely 100 undercut by the
epilogue
which i guessed spoilers because since i
said since structurally it's almost the
exact same film
as the theatrically released justice
league just totally different and
more it's actually almost impossible to
spoil except when it comes to the
epilogue the epilogue's about the one
thing that is almost entirely new
and is actually spoilable so if you
haven't seen it yet i would imagine you
would have
but anyways that's your one spoiler
warning you're gonna get at this point
so the epilogue is another
supposedly hypothetically premonition
nightmare
that bruce wayne has about the future a
future where
aquaman's dead wonder woman is dead and
he has to team up with the likes of
mara deathstroke and the joker to try
and fight back against a superman who is
now
evil and also it's implied that
somewhere along the way lois lane died
and that's what sent superman over the
edge or at least
might have which seems to imply to me
that we're dealing with some sort of
extrapolated or twisted or snyderized
version of the injustice
timeline uh in my opinion of injustice
is very much
thank god it's an alternate timeline and
was never made part of the official
canon because
as an elseworlds cool as your primary
canon
no no but
the whole thing like especially given
that
at least so far as official
there's no word of any kind of sequel
for this and
even if this does really well on
streaming i
i don't i really don't see a sequel
happening
only because for as much additional
money as they had to spend on this
that was still a drop in the bucket
compared to what they had actually
already spent on the dang thing
to allow snyder to do a follow-up
from scratch where most of the movie
wasn't
already filmed as existing footage and
they only had to do pickup shots and a
few reshoots and then some
cgi work i i
don't see how this could ever do enough
enough numbers to justify
a starting from zero follow-up
i i don't that said i didn't think we
were ever going to get this so
i may get proved wrong on that but i'd
be shocked
that's all i'm saying so it's it's odd
to me
that and supposedly it's because this is
how snyder always envisioned the movie
ending so he he
wanted things to wrap up in this way and
set up future stuff and i
i okay but it really does
undercut the sense of
of an ending and of hope that this movie
had left me with and it kind of says to
me that snyder
doesn't believe in hope and doesn't want
to leave you
with a sense of hope he wants to leave
you a sense of dread
which again becomes a very fundamental
philosophical difference between
what i want out of superhero stories and
what
attracts him to superhero stories
his perspective seems to be always
looking towards the next
threat what's the next thing that's
going to make the world terrible as
opposed to
we made the world better for now
uh and the the epilogue really kind of
does speak to that
and that's where some of the additional
cameos come in uh that's where
deathstroke shows up
he shows up before that as well because
apparently the
whole jailbreak with uh lex luthor and
then
deathstroke showing up i guess that
was part of his original plan i'd assume
that was a whedon insert not so much
interesting um but that's where we get
the joker i will say this jared leto's
joker works a heck of a lot better here
than he did in suicide squad
um i really could have done without the
um
the gate the one gay coded line that
actually
really felt horrendously crowbarred in
and did not feel like a natural
extension of the conversation that was
going on
that actually really annoyed me
but remove that line and his performance
is actually decent
and his banter back and forth with ben
affleck is pretty good
so maybe he could even have been a
decent joker
given a better film than suicide squad
to be it in
i don't know i'm not prepared to go that
far but i'm at least prepared to
entertain the
notion because what we get here i can
work with what was in suicide squad was
but i think that's about it again like i
feel like i don't know what to call this
i'm calling it a movie for lack of a
better term
but it's not a movie by most standard
measures
but it's not a mini-series it's not a
duology
it's just the snyder cut it is just its
own
thing and what it is
is pretty good at being what it sets out
to be
much better than batman v superman
because batman v superman is a case of
where i would argue not only is what it
was trying to be
probably not worth being or at least i
don't feel it was something that you
should be doing
i also think it flat out failed at being
it
this isn't that this absolutely succeeds
and for me the debate is whether it was
a good idea in the first place but again
i feel like that's more of a matter of
taste here than is usually the case
that's zack snyder's justice league
did you see it what did you think about
it whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it like share subscribe
the usual stuff i have a patreon if you
are willing to help me out there this is
in fact my living
it is how i pay my bills and there are
perks at every tier there's also youtube
memberships now if you would prefer to
support me that way
but um no pressure
the usual stuff like share subscribes
they help me out as well
but you don't have to do that either
because at the end of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time
this council's adjourned
i actually thought it was good did not
call that
[Music]
[Music]
you um
[Music]